[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah oui
elle est avec nous aujourd'hui
franchement on est tous comme des fous
moi elle je suis allé dans sa loge tout
à l'heure elle m'a parlé et tout j'ai
dit à i like l'oréal à la guilde jojoba
tout ça eva longoria
[Applaudissements]
hall
et
à
m
[Applaudissements]
et merci et quel bonheur boîte bonheur
notre boîte à d'honneur boîte quality
street très énervé coup trottoir bien
oui tu dis tout le monde non non non
j'ai pas dit que j'aimais bien les
cheveux de tout le monde je ne suis pas
spécialement si vous êtes spécial you
are very ai-je piccioli for me
[Applaudissements]
bouchaillou veste en tweed we take my
father
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vois pas je suis pas bien c'est pas
michèle torr l'asim ballons cordes à la
frérot merci eva d'être avec nous few
tubiret tu n'arrêtes on ne touche pas à
alma et posting evans il vous fait
beaucoup de sport d'ailleurs bon ça se
voit vous avez fait du kickboxing il ya
du dogue à yes et il ya un gars aussi
qui était comme un fou vous veniez c'est
jean michel maire alors on va faire un
jeu qui s'appelle deux fils
venez avec moi et une forte oui tout de
suite c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est très simple on va poser des
questions sur la merci des débats on va
poser des questions sur votre vie ok
s'ils répondent bien voulu fait un bisou
s'ils répondent mal vous le yoo fracasse
in what i want you to fracasse à fait
d'accord voici la première question
jean-michel quel est le nom et prénom du
personnage d'eva longoria dans la série
desperate housewives ce soit pour y
jouer je voudrais les propositions
gabrielle solis gabriel salissent
gabriel silice ou gabriel tu brûleront
d'esprit tout d'abord est trop élevé
alors je dirais la réponse à gabrielle
solis
[Musique]
abhisit
[Applaudissements]
voici la deuxième c'est bien et il est
raté serait passé ouais mais ça va se
compliquer avec quels diplômes obtenus
et va à l'université de los angeles un
diplôme contre les cheveux cassants et
les pointes sèches un diplôme de kenzo
logis je poserai diplôme d'avocat pour
un diplôme de cinéma attention ne
trichez pas s'il vous plaît allez
avocate avocate et non elle a un diplôme
de kinésiologie what is what is joe
kinésiologie à la cohésion du corps on
m'a souvent demandé moi que je viens
pour étudier mon corps il me rappelait
plein de fois et vous les décors poilus
alors là alesi et nous est lourd mais le
lourd lourd qui fait genre refaites le
mec qui fait genre et titube
alors studio acton vale attention voici
la dernière quelle est la spécialité que
cuisine le mieux et va la soupe de
tortillas le bois kamal le pépito db là
où le burrito le bout de bois plutôt une
on sait quoi eva guacamole waka waka
molle whack a mole et la souplesse de
zakaria les deux c'est vrai et pas que
vous faites le meilleur guacamole du
monde parce qu'on m'a dit forcément
c'est bon on s'en fout c'est perdu eva
mais la fracasser le faites moi plaisir
aulas laquelle nous écoutent et loire et
van persie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci et bon
et bah non merci
eva eva est ce que vous pouvez me faire
un dernier plaisir
on va mettre une chanson vous allez
faire le rêve de ma vie vous allez venir
m'inviter à danser you are going to
invent me to dancing hier c'est toujours
pas ça touche pas mon kiff aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mais valoir mois de loi de you want to
dance with me salsa salsa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
damas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
oh
mais ce cas tu es jeune et scat et merci
et moi remercie d'avoir etc
merci beaucoup et eva longoria
[Musique]
voilà